welcome back to the stronger by science
multimedia experience
uh i'm your host eric trexler
uh i want to introduce a special
temporary guest co-host his name is greg
knuckles greg thanks for joining me yeah
thanks for having me on this obviously
used to be known as the stronger by
science podcast but now
as some of our viewers can tell on
youtube we have a video component now
we're going to try this out
uh experimentation is the backbone of
science or so they tell me so we're
going to see how this goes try to get
some video along with the audio for our
podcasts
i've got a great show planned for today
a lot of good segments but before we get
into that a couple announcements so
first of all
something that we are really excited
about is we have the big macro factor
live release party um
that is going to be
right here on our youtube channel uh via
live stream we're going to do that
september 16th at 8 00 pm eastern time
so
put on you know that you got the little
app on your phone the world clock just
whatever time it is in new york that's
the time it is here so we're going 8 p.m
eastern time september 16th that's going
to be great it's going to be part
celebration um part infomercial and a
little bit of
we're going to you know answer some live
questions as well keep it
largely nutrition focused but we can
throw some training stuff in there as
well if we want yeah like just imagine
billy mays wasn't just doing cocaine
before filming but actually while
filming uh and that that'll basically be
the the vibe we're going for exactly yes
the famous saying goes there ain't no
party like a greg and eric party
that is the saying uh so in the you know
it's going to be great we've been
putting the app together for a really
long time working on it getting it
finalized and so the 16th is when uh it
launches so if you're interested in
checking it out you can go to
strongerbyscience.com
macro factor right now there's even like
a little countdown there and every time
i open that page i uh get a little bit
nervous you know
good kind of nervous jitters for the big
uh for the big launch we think you we
think everybody's gonna love it so we're
excited to uh finally get that
out of beta testing and into the hands
of the public so stop by for the
celebration stop by to get some
information about nutrition stop by to
learn more about the app it should be a
really fun show the last thing i want to
mention is uh go over to
bulksupplements.com use the discount
code sbs pod in all caps for a five
percent discount on your supplement
order
so greg road to the stage how are things
going
i'd say things are going pretty well um
i i would say i'm fully back in the
swing of things after a vacation and
after being sick for a while uh
my weight trend is the lowest it's ever
been
um occasionally waking up below 245 now
which is nice
uh
and yeah so i i don't really have much
much insight to add um
i would say the small win uh for for the
past two weeks
is that uh one of the things that
for me historically has been really
important when i'm trying to lose weight
is maintaining a really high level of
activity uh helps with appetite
regulation
and uh
contrary to some things that people have
commented on instagram exercise i
believe does actually affect total daily
energy expenditure
um so historically i've i've been
[Music]
only moderately unsuccessful with losing
weight when i'm very active and very
unsuccessful with losing weight when i'm
not as active anyway last few weeks have
been crazy um you know we're in the home
stretch for the app a lot of work to do
i haven't been as active but uh still
stay in the course still losing weight
at the rate that i want to um
yeah not not a huge thing but i i would
count that as a small win
nice and yeah you mentioned it's been
crazy because we timed this really well
leading up into the launch for macro
factor is also like the busy time of the
month writing for the mass research
review
uh so it's been pretty crazy
uh now i've got a little update for the
uh
road to enlightenment you know all roads
we travel are likely to involve some
challenges i'm gonna run into some bumps
along the road
and my path uh brought me to a challenge
so the road to enlightenment is my
journey through secular buddhism to
chill out more which is good
but here's what's not chill
both literally and figuratively
during late august my air conditioner
just completely stopped working so we
live in north carolina the last several
weeks like
basically ever since the day my air
conditioner went out we had like a
10-day stretch where it was like
high 90s
115
humidity uh it's it was just super super
hot and so
that was a big challenge to uh
my
attempt to become a little bit more zen
uh
so there were some wins and losses uh
with that challenge to my path to
enlightenment so on the good side
uh i genuinely did
make peace with just not having air
conditioning during what was really like
the hottest weeks of the north carolina
summer which i was i don't know if uh
a previous version of me could have done
that you know like when you're used to
that convenience and it's super hot it's
easy to get fixated on like dude this
timing sucks i'm very uncomfortable this
is something i believe i deserve to have
because i've always had it you know you
you kind of take those types of
conveniences for granted and then when
they're taken away it can really get
mentally fixated on that and just be a
miserable bastard yeah but like i did
get to a point pretty quickly where i
was like hey there's a lot of people who
live in hot ass places who don't have
air conditioning and like this is fine
we're not in danger yeah it's gonna be
fine so that was the good thing is you
know in in secular buddhism and buddhism
broadly they talk about the middle path
where you don't need to rely on
conveniences to bring you joy you also
don't have to
discard all material possessions you
want to be right in the middle where you
can enjoy some nice things but you don't
need them to be happy yeah and i felt
like that was a pretty cool thing i kind
of shed my attachment to that particular
convenience now here's where it went
wrong
uh so i bought my house very recently um
you know which i'm of course very lucky
to be able to buy a house like that was
a thing that i'm hugely thankful for
um but the reason i bring that up is the
home is still under the home warranty
and
whatever
calmness and zen i had with regards to
the air conditioner the home warranty
people man it was like they were trying
to get under my skin and boy did they
succeed so that that was insane
as you mentioned off air i think home
warranties are just completely a scam oh
100
yeah so that that was quite a racket
that pushed my uh zen buddhist approach
to the absolute limits
uh but overall hey i'll take a half half
win you know we'll get better at the
rest as we go
sounds good to me all right so feats of
strength what do you got pizza strength
yeah i i've only got one um
part of that is that i was uh doing my
outline at about five in the morning and
i had more important stuff i wanted to
deal with in tracking down a bunch of
feeds of strength
um
but also
[Music]
you know what i'm not even going to
throw another excuse out there um
yeah so i've got one today it's about
quality not quantity yeah yeah that's
that's what we'll go with
um
so yeah uh thomas davis we've mentioned
him on the podcast before uh
one of the
i would say currently alarming number of
700 pound dentures for the longest time
there were
two
uh and now there's like it's going
around yeah yeah uh
maybe 700 pound benching is the real
pandemic yeah uh anyway um so he i think
he's hit 705 in a meet before uh but
recently on instagram he posted himself
hitting uh 702 pounds or about 318 and a
half kilos for a double um
second rep you know looked very solid uh
it wasn't a big grind or anything like
that uh but we'll we'll post the uh a
link to the video in the show notes and
i strongly recommend checking it out and
watching it uh just purely i would say
for for the wow factor of it
it might be the most violent bench press
i've ever seen uh and i say that as a
compliment
and when you watch the video you will
fully understand uh he is
it looks like he is in temp attempting
to inflict great malice upon the bar
um
so yeah
very impressive set uh we might have
another
750-pound venture coming in the next
year or so
who's to say uh a lot of strong people
out there and uh thomas davis is
certainly one of them do we have an
update on that big uh
it was supposed to be the the two guys
that were going for like 800 head to
head do we know what happened with that
event
it hasn't happened yet oh it hasn't uh
[Music]
i think it's in january oh okay cool i i
could be wrong yeah the uh uh
julius maddox daniel zamani yeah
face-off yeah i i
i think that meat is either in december
or january okay cool well we'll keep an
eye on it
all right moving on i've got uh a bit of
a brief research review segment here
where i'm going to talk about uh two
pieces of research that
um
made some waves you know generally got
picked up uh by the media and then got
you know
tossed around a little bit on social
media you know throwing the the links
and the headlines around so i wanted to
address these just because so many
people have been talking about them the
first one i want to cover is another
paper that's largely being attributed to
to poncer
although i wouldn't necessarily call it
a paper by poncer necessarily so
in a previous the most recent episode we
talked about that paper where poncer was
the lead author where they were looking
at metabolism across the lifespan um so
go back to the previous episode to get
caught up to date on that particular
research review but in this case it was
the same group of researchers but poncer
was not the lead author in this case he
was the third author but a lot of people
are calling it the ponzer paper because
uh he is an author you know third author
it usually indicates a very substantial
contribution so i don't want to i don't
want to diminish that
um but this is an idea that poncer
really popularized and he's he's if
there's one idea he's known for it's the
topic of this paper so seeing his name
on in the top three on the marquee there
you know a lot of people are are calling
it the ponzer paper uh to some extent
that that's appropriate but i have seen
papers in the past just being in
academic publishing where like
you kind of know who did what on a
project
and like the person who's like lead
author did like 96 of it and everybody's
calling it like
someone else's paper because they're
like
the most famous person on the paper but
they're like sixth out of ten yeah you
know and i'm just like out of respect
for the lead author like you know let's
make sure we're giving credit there but
anyway
this paper came from that big group uh
they're using that data from the
international atomic energy agency
double doubly labeled water database so
this paper is by caro halsey poncer and
a whole bunch of other people that are
associated with that huge group and
they've actually had quite a few papers
coming out i've seen at least three over
the last couple weeks uh utilizing this
database which is awesome because it's
this database is a really cool resource
i'm glad that people are making good use
of it so in this particular study you
know the previous one was looking at
energy expenditure across the life span
this study is looking at energy
compensation so the general question
here is
if somebody increases their exercise or
their activity thermogenesis if they're
expending more energy
from physical activity are they going to
compensate and reduce other components
of energy expenditure
which really ties into poncer's
constrained energy expenditure model the
idea that you know as you increase
activity energy expenditure you know
other components of energy expenditure
such as resting energy expenditure will
get constrained to kind of offset that
to some extent
and so you mentioned that uh takeaway
that a lot of people have had on the
internet is like because of this study
we now know that exercise doesn't
increase your energy expenditure like a
total that's that's a take that i've
seen with uh
alarming levels of frequency yeah so two
specific instances where i've seen this
is you know we use uh activity level
correction factors
in the macro factor diet app when trying
to estimate your when you're just
getting started and we don't have any
data from you it's our kind of
estimation process for your starting
energy expenditure we do have a
correction factor for physical activity
and so some people have asked
why even bother you know and another
thing that's come up that i've seen is
you know just the the general question
does this mean that exercise is useless
in a weight loss program
now with this particular paper they use
the
data from that big data set in this case
they had uh over 1700 participants
because they could only use data where
they had the the doubly labeled water
information for total daily energy
expenditure but they also had resting
energy expenditure measured via indirect
calorimetry so they didn't have that for
every single individual in this data set
uh you know but the last paper had like
6 000 participants or something like
that in this case we're talking about
1700 which is more than your typical
caffeine study for sure yeah you know
exercise science we're usually looking
at like 20 or 30 people so 1700 if we're
lucky if if we're lucky yes so 1700 is a
lie
get eight subjects just say like yeah
it's a pilot study yeah it's fine
um
and so what what they found here was
that uh
the average energy compensation that was
observed in this data set
on average was about 28
and so what that means is you know when
people tried to you know
increase their
uh activity energy expenditure uh or
increase their energy expenditure via
physical activity
um only about 72 of those extra calories
really got added on to the total daily
energy expenditure so if they tried to
increase their energy expenditure by
increasing uh 100 calories of physical
activity their total daily energy
expenditure would only go up by about 72
rather than 100. so
i i just need to fact check something
real quick sure
72 percent is a is a different number
than zero percent right
traditionally okay yeah so
basically what that indicates again
that's the average there so
what that tells us is you know people
who are increasing their physical
activity trying to burn some extra
calories they think they're increasing
it by 100 calories but in reality it's
only going up by
what i say about 72 because there's this
28 that's being compensated by reducing
things like resting energy expenditure
either from basal energy expenditure or
potentially a contribution from
non-exercise activity as well so
reducing those basal processes reducing
non-exercise activity those could be
contributing to this compensation effect
now the effects were similar for males
and females they were similar for young
participants and old participants but
they did seem to to differ based on body
composition so
people that were in the 10th percentile
of the bmi distribution compensated to a
magnitude of about 27 28 percent but
when they looked at the 90th percentile
there was a compensation of about 49
percent
that's a pretty drastic difference going
from uh the people with lower body
weight to the people with higher body
weight and so definitely that would
reinforce this concept that people who
are on the higher end of the bmi
spectrum have a greater degree of
compensation so when they tried to
increase their energy expenditure
through 100 calories of physical
activity total daily energy expenditure
only went up by about half that rather
than the entire hundred calories just as
a representative example so the one
thing that this paper cannot answer due
to the observational nature is
uh what's going on there uh is it the
idea that as you increase adiposity and
accumulate more weight and more body fat
does that increase compensation in a
causative way or is it more likely
that people who compensate more are
more predisposed to accumulating more
body weight and body fat across the
lifetime
since it's observational we can't say
which comes first in that kind of
causative change and we also can't rule
out the possibility that something
completely different is kind of
contributing there but
my if i had to guess uh i think it's
more likely
that individuals who have a high degree
of compensation are probably more
predisposed to accumulating more body
fat over time if i had to
guess
that would be where my money is at but
again with an observational study like
this we can't really say necessarily
which one comes first
yeah so this is purely anecdotal i i
wouldn't be surprised if it's a little
bit of both though yeah um
like as someone who has been
quite large and also considerably
smaller
my my experience has been
that uh
just being like wiped out from
exercise training whatever
did affect me less when i weighed less
and i think part of that is just simply
like dude if you got more of yourself
that you need to get up off the couch
it's a little bit harder to get up off
the couch yeah um
so yeah i mean i i
obviously wasn't doing like w labeled
water experiments on myself though
continuously for the last 15 years
um but i i
i think you are
correct
that it it is more that people who are
predisposed to be larger probably do
just inherently have larger
compensations but i i wouldn't be
surprised if if it's a little of column
and a little of column b just based on
my own experience yeah totally possible
so hopefully uh you know what we'll get
to the bottom of that in the future with
more research so now you're totally
caught up to speed on the whole uh
series of papers that have really caught
the attention of the fitness industry
out of that group and again the
important thing to emphasize here the
compensation was not a hundred percent
it is it is not the case that you know
you would look at this paper look at the
results and say oh i guess exercise
doesn't increase total daily energy
expenditure that really has been one of
one of the more confusing series of
takes that i've that i've seen on social
media probably ever honestly wow
no like if you've been alive in the
world
ever and used your eyes it should be
clear that exercising a lot does
increase the amount of calories you burn
to some degree yeah you know like i mean
yeah if you if you've been on this earth
for long enough to generate
uh observations
that should that should be painfully
obvious
that that is a more painful take to me
than just about anything i've ever seen
yeah and i mean the thing that i thought
of is like if you've ever hung out with
an endurance athlete during a really
high volume stretch of their training
they eat a bagel every 20 minutes like
they are just consuming calories
throughout the day non-stop
and uh notoriously pretty slim endurance
athletes typically it's it's a pretty
notable observation when you're like
dude
do you ever stop eating and it's like
yeah i ran like 40 miles this week i'm
pretty hungry you know that is that even
a high volume for endurance athletes
that would be a high volume for like a a
recreational runner the the pros are
typically
i mean it depends what distance you're
talking about but generally 70 plus
sometimes top and 100 that's a lot
uh all right so the other
study that i wanted to mention here uh
my headline is the fake news
vilification of hot dogs from a state up
north
uh so this is research coming out of
michigan and we're not very fond of
those those individuals during football
season because this is a strong ohio
state football podcast we have not
locked down that sponsorship yet but we
are working diligently
so this is a study out of the university
of michigan and it caught a lot of
headlines because the the kind of easy
takeaway
was that a hot dog reduces uh your
healthy lifespan by like 36 minutes give
or take
um
and so first of all i want us to accept
that at face value and kind of suspend
any skepticism we might have
so
if one hot dog reduces your healthy
lifespan by 36 minutes
and you said you know what i don't care
i really like hot dogs i'm going to eat
for a week for my entire life because it
just means a lot to me you know
so unless i messed up my numbers i'm
pretty certain that
four hot dogs a week at 36 minutes a pop
if you continued that habit for 70 years
of your life you would lose one year on
the back end
[Music]
seems like a not that bad of a trade-off
to me personally i mean i don't eat hot
dogs anymore due to my path to
enlightenment but uh
yeah i mean that that's not as
catastrophic when you start to actually
put some numbers to it and say oh that
that's not particularly scary yeah uh
now
that's if we suspend our skepticism i'm
just going to be honest i have like a
personal bias here with this type of
thing i just really dislike metrics that
lack face validity like because i don't
think you would actually
walk up to somebody in the field of
nutrition and say like
do you
truly believe this statement if you eat
a hot dog it reduces your lifespan by 36
minutes i i don't actually believe
anyone would say i actually believe that
in a literal way and so my i
my perspective is you know we're trying
to i assume quantify these things to
make them more tangible but if we don't
actually believe that tangible
quantification i just don't see why we
really bother with these things i don't
think it's particularly
helpful or useful but that's my personal
opinion i'm sure a lot of really smart
folks disagree with me on that um but i
looked into the paper the scoring system
for how we arrive at this seemed a
little bit opaque to me so i dug a
little deeper and found a dissertation
document by one of the authors
of this paper
and within the dissertation document if
you've ever opened up a dissertation
they're long and they have like 70
tables in them you know it's like all
this like the paper that results from it
is like the highlight reel you know
the dissertation is like usually like
200 pages 36 appendices it's long so
there was all the details in there about
how the scoring system works a couple
things that jumped out to me can i just
throw out a really hot take sure so this
is adjacent to something we've talked
about on the podcast before how uh
there's just there's so many
low impact publications that come out
every year just due to like publisher
parish type pressures
i actually kind of think that
dissertations rock and that's how like
most research should be done
you know just pump out like one
dissertation quality thing per year boom
great and like obviously that wouldn't
make sense for an individual to do now
one because journals wouldn't publish it
word count limits etc
and two because you know even if you
have one high impact pub a year
generally that's going to be looked
poorly upon if people you're competing
against have
15 lower impact pubs
uh but i i think in a perfect world
most most research documents would look
a lot more like theses or dissertations
just because
like you're describing they're uh
they're so much more thorough
you know uh
oftentimes when you're reading an
individual paper you will have questions
after you read the methods section which
should not be the case like the
theoretical purpose of a method section
is if someone wanted to perfectly
replicate your study they could and like
that's kind of rare i think yeah for for
a method section to actually be that
thorough you almost always see that in
dissertations um
and then often like there's a logical
flow to them like they might include two
three four experiments that all build on
each other so you can kind of see how an
idea develops and
multiple layers of evidence supporting
whatever concept it is so i i think in a
perfect world that's how most science
would be done and communicated um
anyway you mentioned dissertations i
just wanted to slide that in there
uh you can keep going all right we'll do
so
so yeah um
basically uh i i took a quick look at
the scoring system a couple things that
jumped out to me were
it was pretty punitive for sodium
and it was a little bit punitive for red
meat as well
and those are kind of those things where
when you start to look at how these
quantifications work
they peel away a lot of the context of
the specific food item and the overall
construction of the diet they try to
boil it down to kind of basic
contributing factors and sometimes it
it's not super helpful to do that you
know so like
if you have a high sodium food in the
context of a diet that isn't
particularly high in sodium or you know
you're an exerciser you have a lot of
sweat loss or you're not particularly
sodium sensitive when it comes to your
blood pressure response to diet like
some of these things start to really
break down in more nuanced applications
so anyway you know these types of
scoring systems i don't really know if i
support the general premise uh
and even if you do they tend to get
pretty overly reductionist and you run
into situations where some foods can
have kind of uh
unexpected
results within the scoring system based
on their various components
um so
one of the other things that jumped out
to me here is i'm not really fond of the
concept of treating risks as these like
perfectly linear things where you do it
once and your lifespan shortens you do
it twice your life span shortens more i
mean
at the end of the day uh you know we're
talking about probability here you know
you could do a
something that is carcinogenic
and if you do that for your entire
lifespan and never end up developing
cancer as a result of that behavior
your lifespan did not shorten due to
that thing
despite the fact that it is known to be
carcinogenic you know i mean you would
want to avoid that if possible but
i don't know if i like
this approach this is probably how like
actuary tables work right
but um yeah i mean if you play russian
roulette six consecutive times with a
single revolver
you will die but
you don't become one sixth dead exactly
yeah
so uh it's something to keep in mind is
like this this whole approach to the
scoring system and the the way it's
treated as this kind of perfectly linear
thing in the headlines i'm not super
fond of now this sounds super critical i
i don't want to just like bash the paper
because it is work that is done well
um you know with people like this stuff
and this is a suitable way to do
nutrition uh kind of like
epidemiological nutrition science so
this is just me being uh a little bit
contrarian just because you see these
headlines that people run away with and
you're like i understand the headline
and where it comes from but i don't
believe that anyone actually believes
that so if you're curious about why you
kept seeing those headlines that's
pretty much
where this comes from but this
particular paper did not introduce
new
evidence you know new empirical evidence
about risks associated with actually
consuming hot dogs they basically said
hot dog okay we've got uh you know uh
super refined bread we've got high
sodium we've got processed meat check
check check 36 minutes so that's where
this came from and i don't put a whole
lot of stock i mean
hot dog is not a particularly healthful
food we knew that before this study we
know that after the 36 minute component
is
very arbitrary in my opinion
now there was an interesting aspect of
this paper that looked at the
environmental impact of foods and it did
the same kind of approach where it tried
to assign a score you know use some
scoring systems to talk about how
choosing a particular food might impact
the environment now i don't have the
skill set to really assess
that type of scoring system i'm not an
environmental scientist but an important
thing to note is that these authors are
environmental scientists part of me you
know if you look at the paper and say
you know what the health and nutrition
stuff let's table that for a moment and
i just want to look at the environmental
impact stuff
i would have to assume
that the environmental impact stuff is
potentially a little bit more uh
rigorous and robust and applicable than
the nutrition side because this phd was
done in environmental health sciences
so that was that part of the paper was
probably more squarely within their
wheelhouse rather than
specifically looking at like nutritional
science or something like that i'm just
guessing but it is it was an interesting
paper to look at some of the
environment related ramifications of
choosing a variety of different foods so
if you're interested in that it's it's a
cool paper for that like i said i don't
have the skill set to really assess
those environmental scores but that is a
rundown of the papers that have been in
the headlines and now greg i understand
that you have a research roundup
yeah i've got a few
um how are we doing on time i i've got
three but i want to make sure we have
time for q a so if
you think it would be best to just do
two i'm fine with that sure do too
all right so uh
i have also got one that is ripped from
the headlines uh
so there was a press release put out
recently uh titled a mathematical model
predicts best way to build muscle um
which you know that's that's obviously a
very audacious title uh that's that's
gonna suck you right in
um
and this uh
press release and the paper underlying
it uh generated enough interest that it
actually batted for the cycle when it
came to
people reaching out to me on every
platform that i can be reached on uh
people posted about this in our facebook
groups they posted about it in the
subreddit they messaged it to me on
facebook they emailed it to me and they
hit me up about it in my instagram inbox
uh so
and and i believe it was different
people every time so
clearly clearly there's general interest
in this
uh
and a lot of people uh who want my take
so i will oblige them
so anyway um like i said the the title
of the press releases mechanical model
or mathematical model predicts best way
to build muscle uh the study underlying
it is titled why exercise builds muscles
titan mechanosensing control skeletal
muscle growth under load
and a lot of the focus on this came from
one key quote from the press release
the quote was and this is from one of
the authors our model offers a
physiological basis for the idea that
muscle growth mainly occurs at seventy
percent of maximum load which is the
idea behind resistance training said
terentagev
below that the opening rate of titan
kinase drops precipitously and precludes
mechanosensitive signaling from taking
place above that rapid exhaustion
prevents a good outcome which our model
has
quantitatively predicted
so anyway i think the reason that this
generated a lot of buzz
is because you have these people doing
like to be clear super nerd level
research
seeming to validate what the bros have
been saying for a long time 70 1rm uh
that's around a 12 rep max load for most
exercises uh and it's you know something
you'd probably be doing for sets of 10
if you're trying to hit failure in about
three four five sets something you'd be
doing for about sets of eight if you
were trained with a few reps left in
reserve so like 70 1rm is like probably
the single percentage
most associated with like the 8 to 12
rep range which is the classical
hypertrophy range
and so uh yeah it's a it's a three rep
max for me
yeah that's fair
uh
do you do you mind if i uh break subject
confidentiality
for my next real quick
uh yeah so so this [ __ ] right
here had the worst bench fresh strength
endurance of anyone in my thesis study
trucks was a subject the the total
number of reps
completed in a single set to failure at
75 1rm
uh it ranged from 6 to 15
and uh
you were the six
mr six
the six god as they say
um
anyway so uh
see i think that's one of the reasons it
generated so much interest you have very
very technical research
seeming to confirm what people have been
saying like quote unquote in the
trenches for a long time uh that that
confluence of events seems very
satisfying and so uh i think a lot of
people were were interested in that
and i think a lot of people uh
specifically wanted my take on it
because
i've been saying for for years now that
you know really the the hypertrophy
range probably isn't as narrow as folks
have been saying um on a per set basis
as long as you're getting pretty close
to failure
anywhere from sets of 20 25 reps on the
light end of things to sets of
probably around five or six reps on the
heavy end of things all seem to promote
hypertrophy
uh pretty much equally well on a per set
basis
um
so anyway since i've been saying that i
i think people were were interested in
in my take on this
and um
anyway the paper did not at all find
that uh
70 of 1rm is the ideal load for
hypertrophy uh but before we can get
into that it's it's worth some
background to talk about what the paper
was actually interested in looking at
uh so just as background uh it's
commonly believed i wouldn't say even
commonly believed it's nearly
universally believed uh that one of the
main precipitators of hypertrophy
signaling is something called
mechanotransduction
so mechanotransduction is basically the
idea that there are proteins
within or surrounding your muscle fibers
that can sense an increase in force
being created by or transmitted through
the muscle
and then once that force is sensed that
kicks off a signaling cascade that
eventually results in increases in
muscle protein synthesis so that's
mechanotransduction
and that like i said that's
almost universally believed to be
either the main or one of the main
initiators of hypertrophy there's some
protein somewhere or multiple proteins
multiple places within your muscles that
are accomplishing mechanotransduction
and that kicks off all of the things
that eventually result in muscle protein
synthesis
and there are several candidate proteins
that might be the main quote-unquote
main
sensor for mechanotransduction
um and what the authors of this paper uh
basically wanted to put forth
is that there is a possible candidate
for the main or or being one of the main
mechano-trans doc
transducers that is maybe not discussed
as often as it should be
so that's referred to as the kinase
domain of titan there are other
potential candidates for
mechanotransduction probably most
notably focal adhesion kinase that kind
of get a lot of press in the mechanistic
like hypertrophy signaling world and
these these authors are basically
arguing that the kinase domain of titan
should be getting
a similar amount of attention because
they think that might be one of the main
mechanotrans transducers
so what they did
is they generated a pretty intricate
model to essentially predict okay what
would acute and chronic responses to
resistance training look like if we
assume
that this particular kinase is the most
important
cytomechanotransduction so if we assume
that this particular region on the titan
protein is your main mechano transducer
what would that predict
uh and so they they generated
uh
i have to give them props for this the
model they generated was ridiculous like
they accounted for so many variables uh
like when they were modeling the effects
of load on like how long this particular
kinase would be open and active they
even modeled like uh
the impact i believe of uh fiber size on
ribosome density within the fiber and
rates of atp usage at different levels
of uh
of contraction strength like there was
there was a
they weren't lazy with model
construction like they accounted for
just about every variable that they
realistically could have
um
but like it did still rest on a lot of
assumptions the main assumption being
it's not proven that this particular
titan-associated kinase is the main
mechano transducer it was basically
assuming
grant us that it is if it is then then
what could we predict
um
and so basically the predictions they
generated from this model were
uh
physiologically plausible and more or
less in line with experimental outcomes
uh so basically the the biggest thing
they were putting forth in their
research is like hey
if we assume that this is the main
mechano transducer we can generate
predictions
that look pretty much like the real
world
therefore
this might be the main mechano
transducer therefore
more research is warranted to see if
that's the case so so that's that's
basically what what they were doing this
was uh
more or less a very very
elaborate hypothesis generating model um
to to put forth
theoretical evidence to suggest that
this particular titan-associated kinase
deserves more actual experimental
research to see if it is as important as
these researchers think it might be like
that that was the main point of the
paper um
so
the big question is this evidence that
70 of 1rm is the optimal intensity for
building muscle
no it's not uh
again the main problem the authors were
addressing is that there's not enough
research on this particular kinase in
the first place
so this paper i would say is basically
two steps away from
uh constituting
evidence that we could use to inform
training prescription
so
this was basically to generate
hypotheses for in vitro research or
animal research and then if they do that
research and it pans out then it'll be
time for human research and probably
three steps away from actual
uh
implementation because
then when you get to human research then
it's going to be mechanistic work acute
work and then maybe longitudinal work to
look at further implications of this
so we're
we're talking about uh
a pretty long
uh research process
potentially leading from this paper to
novel and useful insights about how to
to program training but that's where
things stand now um it's
very very intricate very very cool
modeling work uh
but if you looked at the press release
and you're counting it as definitive
evidence that seventy percent one rm is
for sure the optimal intensity to train
at uh we're
years potentially decades away from
being able to uh
make any sort of statement like that
grounded on
this research as it stands today
yeah the press releases were hilarious
the headlines were like
trainers hate these scientists for
exposing the real keys to muscle gain
yeah it's just not
not what they were doing correct
okay um
let's see one of the other things i was
going to talk about is uh
a study that we recently posted about on
instagram so i'm gonna skip that one and
just say
follow stronger by science on instagram
uh
if you scroll back probably probably i
would say six posts by the time that
this episode is coming out uh you'll see
one with a scatter plot on it uh that
has to do with squatting and ankle
mobility check out that post i i was
basically just going to talk about the
same the same stuff we posted
uh just double dip in a little bit but
anyway i'll skip that one uh so let's
talk about caffeine caffeine's good
stuff if you're following along on video
i've got my coffee uh
i like caffeine it's nice
and uh caffeine is also for the ladies
and that's what we're talking about here
so there was a meta-analysis that came
out a couple years or not a couple years
a couple uh months ago
titled ergogenic effects of acute
caffeine intake on muscular endurance
and muscular strength in women a
meta-analysis
by gargic and del coso
um
and and this this was i would say an
important meta-analysis
because uh you know we've talked about
how caffeine is a useful ergogenic for
increasing force output and increasing
strength endurance
on the podcast several times um
and i think we have touched on
uh sex differences in caffeine
metabolism um
but but there's there was some degree of
trepidation
uh certainly within my brain and also
within the research community about
whether or not
research on the ergogenic effects of
caffeine generalized from males to
females
there were a couple reasons for that
first off
a couple of the early papers
looking at
the the potential ergogenic effects of
caffeine in women failed to find
significant effects whereas similarly
design studies did find significant
effects in males
so there were some early suggestions
that maybe caffeine
was ergogenic in males but not females
secondly it's known that
estrogen affects caffeine metabolism
specifically it affects the functioning
of the cyp182 gene which is
uh er the cyp182
enzyme which is the rate limiting enzyme
and caffeine metabolism
um that carries the load for like 95
percent of caffeine metabolism yeah yeah
um
so you know uh and
there are also some suggestions that say
cyp182 gene variants might affect uh
caffeine metab well they certainly
affect caffeine metabolism and
potentially therefore the ergogenic
effects of caffeine although that's not
quite as clear so you know maybe if if
there's a hormone that's affecting
caffeine metabolism that could affect
the ergogenic effects
differently in males versus females uh
and also some degree of trepidation just
related to the fact that there was
there was very little research
uh looking at the potential ergogenic
effects of caffeine in women so just to
illustrate uh there was a 2020
meta-analysis
looking at the impact of caffeine on
strength and strength endurance
this was not a meta-analysis that
specifically
uh restricted
i was checking her real quick to see if
you were an author on it you were not
when was uh when was the meta on
caffeine that you were a co-author on
is that like 2018 2019 something like
that the years all blend together yeah
whatever um so
so yeah the the most recent
meta-analysis looking at the general
ergogenic effects of caffeine on
resistance training acute outcomes uh
was was published in 2020
it didn't restrict the subjects to
only males but 19 studies were included
and of the 19 studies 15 used
exclusively male subjects
two used mixed sex cohorts that were
still very strongly slanted towards male
subjects so
one had 11 total subjects including nine
males and two females one had 17 total
subjects with 13 males and four females
and of the 19 studies only two used
exclusively female subjects
um so you know we're talking about
theoretically uh
a meta-analysis on the effects of
caffeine
independent of sex but functionally it
was a meta-analysis on the impact of
caffeine in males
because males accounted for 87 of the
subjects in the studies included in that
meta um so even relative to exercise
science generally the caffeine research
was very very slanted towards having
male subjects
there's a 2014 paper that that people
bring up a lot
showing that in exercise and sport
science research about 60 percent of the
subjects are male about 40 percent
female um so when when you're looking at
87 male subjects in a particular body of
research you're
you're really dealing with a body of
research where um
you know the the potential impact of
what whatever you're studying on
women and females is uh
is very underrepresented in in the body
of literature as it stands
so anyway that was the state of of the
research in 2020
but since then there's been a
explosion of sorts in caffeine research
in women so in in the meta-analysis i'm
going to be talking about here very
briefly
there were eight studies included
looking at the impacts of caffeine
versus placebo
on
one rm strength and measures of strength
endurance
and of the eight studies included five
of them were published in either 2020 or
2021
so
a majority of the research looking at
the effects of caffeine on resistance
training outcomes in women has been
published in the last year uh and with
that in mind
uh yeah they performed a a competent
meta-analysis looking at the effects on
one rm strength and strength endurance
and found that caffeine has a small
positive effect on one rm strength and
strength endurance
in women
and the effect size estimates
from this meta-analysis were virtually
identical to the effect size estimates
observed in the
prior meta-analysis i mentioned that
came out in 2020 and basically included
all male subjects uh so
currently at this point it seems that
caffeine is also ergogenic in women and
is similarly
the ergogenic effects are
pretty similar uh regardless of sex so
uh that's where that's where the
research stands currently and uh
i gotta i gotta i got
can't talk i gotta be honest it was nice
uh
seeing how many more studies in the area
have been published in the last year
um for
for us to be able to uh
see a meta-analysis on it and uh
be able to make that comparison
yeah it's cool because uh you know i see
del coso
uh in the outline here
it was a few years back i think his
group published a paper
and the entire purpose of the paper was
to bring awareness to the fact that it
was like hey there's a huge absence of
caffeine research in women uh and so it
looks like people saw that paper and
said yep we got it took that directive
and now we're starting to see some of
that research finding its way into
journals and you got to understand that
there's going to be a lag time there
usually of at least one to two years but
often longer when you know from the time
a research idea is formed and then the
study gets planned ethics approval
recruitment data collection writing
rejection rejection rejection yeah i
mean yeah and it can be several years so
i think we're starting to see
uh you know some of the uh fruits of
that labor when it comes to bringing
awareness to uh
why is that funny no i i was just
thinking you know of other times that's
happened um
probably the big the biggest example i
can think of is uh
and this kind of circles back to
the first uh paper i talked about the
modeling paper from from the research
roundup uh
the
uh low load versus moderate load
hypertrophy research uh there was that
paper by by mitchell
i think in 2013 2014 which was just
looking at unilateral knee extensions 80
versus 30
finding pretty similar hypertrophy which
at the time was was a pretty novel
finding
and then
uh
like you said it takes about two years
to get new studies out
you could have set a clock from the time
that mitchell paper was published two
years later there was a deluge of like
a dozen studies coming out over the span
of about 18 months
largely confirming those findings but uh
but yeah i mean there there was a very
influential paper
about a year two years of lag time and
then boom everybody uh everybody starts
getting in on it
yeah which which is exactly how it
should work correct
a lot of times you'll see people who
have an idea that they're very fond of
and they'll say but there is evidence
for this and they'll show you one paper
with like 24 participants and you're
like
let's wait until that next wave of eight
or ten
other papers comes out and see if we can
you know figure out the pattern there
yeah so
uh it's good to see for sure i get
nervous anytime i say something
especially if it's a saying or a phrase
and you start laughing because like
i
i don't read and i don't
consume
really any type of content and so i
don't know how people speak these days i
feel like i'm always like
walking into some kind of linguistic
trap whenever that happens but i'm glad
to see that uh you were just thinking of
something else
um no whenever uh
i think my knee jerk response to just
about anything that happens in my brain
is to giggle yeah that's good it's fine
all right uh moving on i've got a very
very brief coach's corner segment in a
previous coach's quarter segment i
talked about
three different ways to try to estimate
your total daily energy expenditure
which is always a great place to start
if you're thinking about
putting together a diet whether it's
going to be a weight loss diet a
maintenance diet a weight gain diet you
want to start by getting a calorie
target and figuring out your total daily
energy expenditure is going to be very
very informative for that so i talked
about three different approaches that
you could take you could assume you
could estimate or you could observe and
you could go back to that episode i
think it was the most recent episode
where i walked through those those three
different approaches but now i want to
kind of extend those three different
approaches and talk about
how we would use those to actually set a
calorie target rather than just simply
estimating total daily energy
expenditure so if you want to do the
assume approach this is where we're
making a very
uh
very basic assumption it's not
particularly detailed or nuanced for
some people it simply won't work well
but you could make an assumption based
on calories uh relative to body weight
so uh you could think of it as being you
know 15 calories per pound of body
weight in many cases
is going to put you around maintenance
and you can think of that as 15 plus or
minus one so like 14 to 16 for a lot of
people
and 15 calories per pound is equivalent
to 33 kilocalories per kilogram okay and
when i say calories here i'm talking
about kilocalories just to be clear so
15 calories per pound or 33 calories per
kilogram will put you right around
maintenance plus or minus uh you know
that that range i mentioned
if you wanted to push a cut pretty hard
you might go down all the way to about
11 calories per pound or 24.2 calories
per kilogram
physique athletes who you know are kind
of lower on the energy expenditure
spectrum sometimes they'll go down as
low as 10 or even 9
calories per pound for brief periods of
time at the end of their prep it's
brutal it's very low calorie intakes but
i know some people are going to look at
these numbers in bulk and say no i need
way fewer calories if i'm cutting so
for an aggressive cut in my opinion is
usually around 11 but you will sometimes
see instances where to get really really
lean late in the diet you do have to go
below 11.
uh for a bulk you know moderate bulk
might be up around 17 calories per pound
and aggressive bulk would be a little
bit higher up around 19 calories per
pound again these are all plus or minus
one give or take
this is a really rough estimate that
we're getting here i we we posted about
this today on instagram and people
already were saying those estimates
don't really work for me uh and that is
not just understandable it's to be
expected you know rough estimates are
going to have areas where they simply
don't work well
for a given individual that's why in
macro factor we don't use this concept
at all this is just kind of the easiest
most straightforward basic way to do it
a more nuanced approach which is
particularly useful if you have no data
about an individual's energy expenditure
or energy intake and body weight changes
over time if you're just starting with a
blank slate we could use the estimate
approach where we would use you know
some type of equation and some type of
activity correction factor to estimate
total daily energy expenditure and then
we would just set the calorie target
based as a percentage of total daily
energy expenditure so um you know we
talked about the harris benedict
equation is pretty good for for uh
people who don't do resistance training
i think the cunningham equation is great
for people who do lift weights and do
resistance training but you want to use
one of the very common uh estimation
equations and then you want to use the
activity correction factors i think ours
are better than the standard because the
standard ones
kind of don't make sense i'm not saying
ours are perfect either i mean like you
know it's hard to try to do an activity
correction factor one of the things that
makes it difficult to make them perfect
is the fact that uh exercise doesn't
affect the total data energy we should
have put out a table and every cell on
the table just says zero don't worry
about it
so anyway you're going to get your total
daily energy expenditure estimate if you
want to do an aggressive cut you might
be eating like 60 to 70 percent of
estimated total daily energy expenditure
moderate cut will probably be about 80
to 90 percent so you'll be in a 10 20
deficit maintenance obviously is just
100
moderate bulk would be up around 105 to
110 percent and then an aggressive bulk
you'd be eating 115 to 120 of your
estimated total daily energy expenditure
some people might think you know oh i
could push harder than that if i'm bulk
i could go higher and that's ultimately
going to depend on what kind of a hurry
you're in
you know how much adipose tissue you're
comfortable gaining during that muscle
gaining phase and also what your
potential for muscle gain is you know
people who have really great muscle
building genetics who are early in their
lifting career they probably can get
away with pushing some pretty serious
caloric surpluses because they've got a
whole bunch of capacity to add muscle
quickly and adding muscle quickly is a
process that requires a lot of energy
now the third approach is observe and
you know when we talked about total
daily energy expenditure we talked about
observing your energy intake changes in
body weight using that to make
inferences about uh changes in total
daily energy expenditure and the total
uh energy content of one's body you know
based on changes in in body composition
so with the observe approach
it's the same kind of deal we want to be
watching changes in body weight over
time and using that to guide whether or
not we need to change our calorie target
so
you know if you are using this observe
approach what you're doing is tracking
your calorie target tracking changes in
body weight and composition
and then basically titrating your
calorie intake from there aiming for a
particular rate of weight change whether
it's weight loss or weight gain so if
you're on a pretty aggressive cut you
might be losing body weight at over one
percent of body weight per week uh you
know one one and a half
usually that's about where you're going
to find things if you're go if you start
getting over too far over
one and a half percent of body weight
per week it starts to get pretty
aggressive it's it's not a particularly
enjoyable process there
moderate cut is usually 0.25 to 1 of
body weight loss per week maintenance
obviously is just keeping body weight
pretty stable a moderate bulk you might
be looking to gain 0.1 to 0.25 percent
of body weight per week and with an
aggressive bulk you might be gaining
over 0.25 percent of body weight per
week uh so there are kind of the three
different approaches
uh extending those from estimating total
daily energy expenditure taking it a
step further and seeing how those would
ultimately lead to
uh you know recommendations in terms of
a calorie target for a variety of
different goals uh and you know whether
you choose between a moderate or a more
aggressive cut a moderate or a more
aggressive bulk a lot of contextual
factors that go into that these general
guidelines don't necessarily work
perfectly for everyone especially the
first couple approaches uh have some
limitations where there are people who
just are on the higher or lower end of
the spectrum for total daily energy
expenditure there are people for whom uh
some of those estimation equations don't
work perfectly well especially like
catch the the harris benedict and
cunningham ones i think are kind of the
cream of the crop but there are some
ones that are commonly used that
for certain uh for certain uh
populations they just don't work
particularly well so these are to try to
get within the ballpark but the observe
approach where you're actually making
changes based on changes in body weight
over time is a really tried and true
method to make sure that you're keeping
on track and so obviously with macro
factor when we have you know changes in
body weight we've got all your daily
caloric intakes we're able to update
those calorie targets on the fly that's
really the basis of how we do it
all right so moving on we've got uh
q a section do you want to kick us off
here with your first question yeah let's
do it this this will be a quick one so
uh hayato nishiyama asks in the facebook
group uh he said he's interested in my
take on the press out rule in olympic
weightlifting
uh so to to answer or to give my take
somewhat more broadly
i don't like rules
that
make any sort of strength uh competition
type thing
about more than just moving the weight
from a to b and i also don't like
judgment calls from refs uh so
i think in general i like strongman
rules for things like oh hey that bar's
on the ground needs to wind up over your
head
uh figure it out for yourself and as
long as it gets up there it's good um
i like i like that personally uh to me
strength sports are just about moving
weights from a to b i don't
uh
i don't know
i don't think it needs to be more
complicated than that and i also don't
like judgment calls so uh press outs are
something where it's it notoriously
comes down to judgment calls where you
know one judge like a little wobble of
the elbow is fine another judge will uh
will give you red lights for that
and so like yeah i i'm not crazy about
the press out rule i i don't think
removing it would really
change the sport all that much
uh
news flash like you can jerk more than
you can shoulder press and so you know
it's not like oh hey people don't have
to to get to full elbow extension
immediately like now they can
lift 25 more kilos than they used to
before like because it so
i'm using uh i'm just trying to make
some inferences here the pr the press
out rule i guess oh yeah yeah if they
determine in olympic weightlifting that
you are
pressing the weight to get to a lockout
position yeah that's worth that's worth
explaining so um
for for both the snatch and the clean
and jerk
basically you you need to have one
one immediate motion for the bar to get
to a locked out position so for the jerk
if you're like if you catch the bar
here like two inches from lockout and
then press it the last two inches that's
a press out doesn't count uh but where
the judgment call comes in is like
sometimes you jerk it
uh
like your elbows are locked but then
maybe you got under it a little too far
and the weight crashes on you a little
bit you barely unlock your elbows and
you press it back out some judges will
count that some won't
and yeah i i don't like that and i and
that extends to other sports so like one
of the dumbest rules i think in power
lifting is that uh like a squat or a
bench doesn't count if there's any
downward motion during that i hate that
dude you're just making it harder you
know like you're you're not making a
it's not like someone can cheat and be
like ah yes i found
the ideal way to squat if i give myself
a little dip midway up
it makes it easier to stand up that's
stupid like yeah if uh if so if someone
goes all the way down and stands all the
way up
they squatted the weight you know i
don't know what to tell you
um
the only one where
i think it really makes much of a
difference and and so to be clear i
especially think that this take holds
when you're dealing with things that
don't really affect performance all that
much um
so like i said the press out rule i
think if you got rid of it you're not
going to see people
jerking 30 more kilos than they were
previously like it's something that's
just going to matter on the margins if
you allow people to have a slight
downward motion of the barbell when they
squat or bench it's not going to help
anyone it just helps
like it'll allow people to get white
lights when they would have gotten reds
but like it's not going to
raise the ceiling of the sport by 50
kilos or whatever
the the only one where
uh i think it's not quite as
straightforward
is hitching and ramping on the deadlift
because that legitimately could help
someone lift quite a bit more
um maybe comes with some degree of
increased risk
i personally still like
still like hitching and ramping i think
it's fine
um
because again it removes a judgment call
like there are some ramping calls that
are
that are judgment calls uh hitching not
so much but i don't know i
to to go back to what i said previously
if the bar starts where it's supposed to
and ends up where it's a where it's
supposed to i think it should count as a
lift um so that's just my personal
opinion
yeah
man
so we we've
influenced a lot of legislation through
the podcast before
and if there's one thing that i could
influence currently
uh speaking of judgment calls the the
in college football getting thrown out
of the game for targeting that is
completely incidental in nature yeah it
it's hard to watch man like dude i get
like you want to keep the players safe
of course you do
but like
throwing someone out of a game for an
unintentional action cannot really be an
effective deterrent like it was an
involuntary thing that occurred yeah uh
that rule is terrible i know no one in
our audience really cares to hear this
discussion but dude they got to do
something like like in basketball where
it's like okay you got two technicals
that's over the line you know we'll give
you one warning in a game
or like or a flagrant one flagrant too
yeah or you know find a way to be like
okay did that look like there was really
malicious intent or is that just the way
football works you know but man this
weekend it was hard to watch some of
those calls because you're like no one
no one in the stadium thinks that was
done intentionally with any you know
intention to do harm yeah you know
terrible
anyway
moving on here
i've got a question from
lucia lopez vasquez
and the question is is organic food
worth the price
uh and man this takes me back to a story
i'm we i'm i'm genuinely annoyed about
how i learned about the dirty dozen uh
which is a list created by a group
called the environmental working group
and i'm paraphrasing but it's basically
like these 12 foods are you know they're
riddled with pesticides don't touch them
you know they're very very bad news uh
as you can tell i'm not reading off the
website that's just kind of my vague
recollection of what the dirty dozen
represents
um
so my introduction to this concept was
actually in a college course that i was
taking
uh
at the doctoral level so i was taking a
phd level course uh at a a pretty decent
university
uh you know my my professor had like
uh
you know another appointment i believe
at harvard and like you know it's always
like oh hey this is this should be
pretty rigorous stuff i'm getting here
and as i was taught as a doctoral level
student it was like yeah the dirty dozen
very good list this is how science works
uh don't touch any of these foods it's
very bad and i'm like you know
as a doc student
your coursework you're like running like
seven studies and you have to like
sneak out of the lab to go take a class
and it's really just a break from doing
your research you know like i mean so
you're not going to be
in a class and say you know what after
class i'm going to spend three hours
fact checking everything i just heard in
that lecture yeah like unless it's
something that's critically important to
you and has some kind of translation to
your research line you're probably going
to say okay that's fine you know if you
put that on the exam i'll give it back
to you you know
so
i was taught that this is very robust
science and then
eventually over the years you know i had
a little bit more free time i kept
hearing it come up again and again you
know you can find several
uh articles on the internet about you
know asking experts how they feel about
this dirty dozen uh there are
peer-reviewed studies looking at uh you
know some of the dirty dozen stuff and
i don't know if i've ever seen an expert
in this area who takes that list
particularly seriously and the reason i
bring up this dirty dozen list is
because when people start making the
argument like hey you really ought to be
buying organic produce the first thing
they send you is this dirty dozen list
of like these 12 foods which happen to
be extremely common uh you know types of
produce they're like dude you cannot be
getting these conventionally for these
12 at minimum you got to be going
organic uh and so there's a paper by
winter and cats where they kind of
looked at
the methodology associated with putting
this list together and the actual
contents of the list back in like 2011
and of course it gets updated like every
year but like the three main points in
this paper were uh you know
the exposures that they're talking about
here uh have negligible risk to
consumers so you could look at a list
and say these are the 12 most you know
you know highest density of whatever
contaminant you want to put on the list
but they're like fine but we're talking
about 12 that still fall well within
safe ranges so you're you're making this
list but it's of no consequence when it
comes to the actual exposure level it
would be like if someone put out a list
that's like the 12 menu items at
mcdonald's most likely to kill you
immediately after eating them right like
maybe you could quantify that but like
you're probably not going to die
immediately after eating any of them
right so so the first part was like dude
even except for the uh [ __ ] what do they
call it the fish one
fish fillet oh it's vile
yeah it is pretty gross i don't like
that yeah uh mcgriddles though are
pretty dude
mcgriddles are elite yeah yeah that is
uh
honestly all of mcdonald's breakfast
yeah hard to go wrong and lunch at
dinner for the most part honestly that's
true yeah just get rid of the fish one
and and we'll be good yeah uh so the
first point was like listen
the exposure of these top 12 is not
inherently deleterious or troublesome
the second point they made was that if
you took these 12 and substituted
organic ones in
uh you are not going to have an
appreciable reduction of risk within
point number one like okay even if you
reduce these values we're still going to
end up within a very uh acceptable range
in terms of exposure
and then the third point they brought up
was that they felt that the methodology
used by this group to rank these top 12
uh lacked scientific credibility um it
was a little bit
arbitrary in terms of how the list was
put together so
um
when it comes to you know a lot of times
i'll have people ask me should i you
know do i really need to be paying extra
for organic produce
from a health perspective and ultimately
your health decisions are up to you but
i have not seen any convincing evidence
that it's a critically necessary step to
take i personally
consume all
conventional produce i have
literally no concern about doing so and
i have looked into some of the research
in this area stuff i don't know much
about sometimes with the conventional
versus organic
produce arguments
you will see people talk about ethical
considerations environmental
considerations i'm going to be honest i
really don't know much about those sides
of the conversation but from a pure
health perspective i haven't seen any
convincing evidence to indicate that
everyone needs to broadly switch over to
organic produce and i think in some
cases the messaging
is counterproductive and harmful because
a lot of people who have really tight
budgets for their food purchases are
being told like hey all those vegetables
that you can easily afford forget all
that just get a few of these vegetables
that you actually can't
you know you're going to have to
basically reduce your vegetable intake
in order to step up and spend the same
amount of money on produce yeah
i think you know
for people who are looking for
vegetables for health-related uh you
know nutritional support on a budget i
think in many cases like what i do
personally i go for
conventional produce and i go frozen a
lot of times rather than fresh
because people think about frozen you
think about the fast food commercials
where everybody brags like ah we never
freeze our stuff
but frozen produce actually holds a lot
of the micronutrient content pretty
effectively so uh that's how i go about
making my produce purchases makes sense
to me personally i buy uh three things
organic and it is
uh
purely a flavor thing i i shop at
wegmans and the wegmans that i shop at
the organic shiitake mushrooms
for whatever reason just generally have
a lot better texture than the
conventional ones
although i don't even know what that
looks like uh like i understand what
organic versus conventional production
looks like for for plants fungi i don't
even know what that means uh but anyway
their organic shiitake mushrooms tend to
be better than the conventional
same thing applies to the ginger
i don't know why their conventional
ginger tends to be like somewhat
flavorless and like a little bit too
stringy they're organic very nice
uh and uh green onions as well but uh
yeah it's purely just because uh
i was not a huge fan of the texture or
flavor of the conventional ones i said
i'll give the organic a shot
and then i liked it and i said god damn
it because i feel the same way
i
ideologically want to use conventional
produce for everything uh so discovering
a few organic products that uh to me
seemed like truly superior alternatives
just from a culinary perspective uh
it annoys me every time i buy them but i
still do yeah it was funny i was on a
farm a few years ago uh talking to the
farmers and they're like
man it's so expensive to certify your
products organic and jump through all
the hoops and they're like
most of the stuff we farm out here is
organic but we only fi filed the
paperwork for one of the the commodities
that we farm i was like oh which one
they said the tobacco
i got a kick out of that
oh that's awesome yeah all right you're
up yeah uh so rackham carlson asks in
the facebook group uh given the recent
news about age and metabolism maybe a
quick overview of what we know about
aging and physical performance what
kinds of performance can be expected to
drop and uh how much and at what ages
um
so yeah this was a reference to the last
episode we put out um
so uh eric mentioned that he just that
he discussed other ponzor papers
previously when he discussed the one in
this episode one of those related to
metabolism and aging so if you haven't
listened to that uh go back and listen
to the prior episode where uh where eric
talked about that uh but yeah so rackham
is asking about performance so different
types of performance how quickly do they
drop off
and kind of
how long can you really be expected to
hold on and be able to maintain
performance
and largely
power based and velocity-based
performance drops off the quickest
followed by strength performance
followed by
endurance performance cardiovascular
endurance
power and velocity-based stuff
generally starts dropping off in your
20s or maybe your 30s if you're really
really training for it um
you
don't see
many
uh elite level sprinters having a lot of
success past their their early to mid
30s
uh and the ones that do
this this doesn't count as a legally
actionable allegation but many of the
ones that do succeed a little bit later
into their career uh maybe have
previously been busted for doping in the
past or are connected to coaches uh who
have had a lot of athletes both uh
busted for doping so
do with that information what you will
uh for for
top-level power velocity-based stuff
generally that starts dropping around
your 30th birthday and you know by
training you can you can maintain it as
well as could be hoped for uh but that
is it's going down
um
as far as strength goes
generally uh you can you can maintain
all or the vast vast majority of your
strength through your 40s and still
maintain it reasonably well uh through
through your 50s into your early 60s
generally for for most people even if
you keep training hard uh
the rate of decrease is generally going
to pick up a little bit by your mid-60s
certainly into your 70s
uh and that uh that pattern holds true
as well for endurance performance
i i'd say you can you can be
very very close to your peak probably a
little bit longer for endurance
performance than for strength um but
it's a similar story
you know probably starts dropping off in
your 40s picks up a little bit in the
50s
but doesn't doesn't really start turning
down until uh mid 60s into your 70s
so um yeah overall
for most of your healthy lifespan you
you can maintain uh strength and
endurance strengthen endurance pretty
well but uh power and and peak velocity
uh
drop off pretty quickly quite a bit
earlier so uh
that's what i would say cool why don't
you jump to your next one i know that
you had a profound emotional attachment
to getting all your q a questions in
um so you know
looking at the clock i want to make sure
that you have the opportunity to do that
uh
sure
those those were honestly the two that i
wanted to answer the most but uh that's
fine
um see i i've got i've got two more that
are um
also going to be pretty short answers
from reddit one is from
heyhoyo4321
who asks
what do you think about bulking or how
do you think bulking and cutting phases
can impact long-term health and
longevity with the cutting phases
mitigate the potential negative health
effects of the bulking phases is there
any evidence that bulking and cutting
affects lifespan
do you think bulking could increase
accumulation of atherosclerosis earlier
in life i know you're not medical
doctors that is very true why do people
always point that out that's so
disrespectful when they point that you
have a doctorate from the school of
medicine that's true so you're
basically a medical doctor i'm not
though uh for everyone listening uh
opinions differ uh i know you're not
medical doctors but it would be
interesting to hear your opinions and uh
yeah blah blah blah so basically
that that was too dismissive and and
what would you answer if a client asked
you these questions that's how it
actually finished uh so yeah i
again to be clear don't uh don't take
this as medical advice at all
um
it is uh a relatively consistent finding
that yo-yo dieting isn't a particularly
great thing
for both long-term health outcomes and
just long-term weight and body
composition outcomes
um
but i
suspect
that a lot of the negative effects seen
with yo-yo dieting
have
less to do with weight loss and weight
gain in particular and more with the
types of diets people are using to lose
weight and then also the rate at which
they're regaining weight so
um you know obviously crash dieting
isn't great and on the the topic of
weight regain
um unless you're
unless you're
very
very
uh underweight or
you know if you're a bodybuilder and
you're like four percent body fat and
gaining weight after a show uh those are
those are pretty much the only times
that maybe a relatively quick
weight or rate of
weight gain or regain
uh
is probably neutral to beneficial for
general health most of the time
uh gaining weight
especially very quickly
not particularly a good thing but i i
kind of suspect that um
if if your
weight trajectory is
also going up and down but you're not
dealing with you know rapid decreases
rapid increases if it is more like oh
hey like i'm doing a bulking phase and
i'm going to put on
15 pounds over the next 18 months or
something like that like a very very
uh modest rate of weight gain and also
not just crash dieting at the end of it
i i suspect that that um that mitigates
a lot of the negative effects that are
often associated with yo-yo dieting so i
suspect
that there really wouldn't be
any or many uh long-term deleterious
effects
uh but that's also
that's an area where there's no research
you know there's a decent bit of
research on on yo-yo dieting
but
you know there
there aren't that many people relative
to the world population who
go on purposeful
uh
multi-month multi-year
gradual books gradual cuts
certainly not enough for
you know researchers to gather a
thousand of them to see what what the
health implications are over 20 years
um so yeah i i can't pretend like that's
a research-backed answer but that's
um
that's what i suspect to be the case
like as long as you're taking things
pretty gradually uh i think it's
probably fine but again that is that is
not medical advice yeah i'm excited
about your next one because this relates
to
a mass article that i wrote recently in
the most recent issue actually do you
want to take it uh no you go ahead
all right uh so drain sync asks in the
stronger by science subreddit how does
eating before bed affect sleep quality
and time to fall asleep
um
so yeah uh
and and there were
follow-up responses to this of people
saying like hey i i'm on a diet or i'm
working with a nutrition coach who's
telling me to eat a large protein bolus
late at night
but then i also do sleep tracking and
sleep tracking says like oh no that you
don't like that
you're taking longer to fall asleep not
sleeping as well so
what do you do
and so basically i think it's important
to note that you can't
you can't necessarily
interpret eating here as a binary
variable like
either you're eating or you're not and
all eating is the same
so there's a
there was a recent review paper i think
from from 2016 uh the title is effects
of diet on sleep quality and uh saint
aung is the
uh lead author there
so we'll link that in the show notes but
the uh
the very very quick and dirty uh version
of the takeaways from that review paper
is that there's some evidence to suggest
that a decent bolus of carbohydrate
before bed might improve some sleep
outcomes maybe reduce sleep onset
latency
maybe increase proportion of rem sleep
uh and the opposite is true for a
relatively high fat intake immediately
before bed that could increase sleep
onset latency and maybe decrease
proportion of rem sleep a little bit um
and then uh another thing worth noting
so one an idea that i've seen seen
bandied about that i gotta be honest uh
i assume there's research out there on
it but i personally haven't looked that
far for it or that hard for it but but i
do know mechanistically
one of the things people point out
is that uh branched chain amino acids
compete with tryptophan for
the same the same receptor for like
uptake into the brain to across the
blood brain barrier
uh tryptophan
is a uh main component of some of the
neurotransmitters that you're trying to
produce as you're kind of calming down
falling falling asleep
and so there's there's some degree of
suggestion that uh
you know i'm not talking about bcaa
supplements in particular but having a
large protein bolus that has a large
proportion of branch chain amino acids
so like basically any any animal protein
um
may not be a particularly good idea
because you could see some competitive
inhibition with tryptophan um
but again i i haven't
looked too hard to see if that does
actually pan out in practice maybe you
have more insight on that
um
but yeah so
decent bit of carbs probably fine a lot
of fat not great ton of protein
potentially not great although that's a
bit more of a gray area
um
and yeah it just in general as well
there's
some evidence to suggest and i wouldn't
necessarily
stake my career and reputation on this i
wouldn't stake my career in reputation
on any sort of uh
nutrition related subject that's that's
your department um but
uh there's some research suggesting that
just for
a host of outcomes
um
consuming a slightly larger proportion
of your calories a little bit earlier in
the day and a slightly smaller
proportion of them later in the day and
especially late at night uh can improve
multiple outcomes
for for a deeper dive on that uh danny
lennon wrote an article for the site on
chrononutrition that we can uh that we
can link in the show notes but yeah in
general
may not be a terrible idea just to try
to eat more of your calories earlier in
the day so you're not having to consume
a large bolus of food late at night
but if you do need to consume or if you
just prefer to consume something before
bed
might not be a terrible idea to kind of
save some carbs for late at night and to
eat that before bed rather than a ton of
fat or a ton of protein but
uh
yeah that's that's about all i got
yeah um
there's also some interesting evidence
related to uh
hunger and fullness in proximity to when
you go to bed
uh pretty strong evidence that going to
bed hungry can lead to some
slightly impaired sleep
but also some evidence that if you have
a huge meal right before bed especially
a high-fat meal
that could potentially impair sleep i do
wonder when people report
the high protein intake
uh as being disruptive i wonder how much
of that is related to the branch chain
amino acid side of things
and how much could potentially be
related to just
you are doing a whole bunch of digestion
at the time that you're laying down to
sleep you know if it's just too much
food that takes too long to digest in
too close proximity to bedtime
because you know like you said
tryptophan critically important it's a
precursor to serotonin and melatonin
which are both heavily tied into this
the onset of sleep
but in a recent paper i covered in mass
they found that
you know when uh individuals
supplemented their dinner at night with
a pretty big dose of whey protein uh the
ratio of tryptophan to branch chain
amino acids was not affected in an
unfavorable way
um and so there should not have been an
issue with that uh tryptophan transport
through that shared transporter
and also the thing that really matters
is you know sleep quality did not
deteriorate within that context but it
wasn't whey protein a moment before
going to bed nor was it you know a mixed
meal a moment before going to bed they
had uh some time there to kind of get
the digestion process started so
sometimes people do ask like hey should
i be worried about whey protein in the
evening based on the evidence available
which is actually surprisingly quite
direct with that new study it's only one
study that i'm aware of but i i don't
see reason to induce too much panic
about uh
whey protein before bed but i would say
hey if you're gonna have a huge filling
mixed meal with a bunch of protein
10 20 30 minutes before you lie down for
bed that's probably not going to be
conducive to a good night of sleep in my
opinion
did
did they look at sleep quality in any of
those uh pre-sleep casein studies
not to my knowledge there have been like
four or five of those at this point
there have i know uh dr ormsbee down at
florida state uh did quite a few studies
in that area with pre-pre-bed uh protein
i cannot recall off the top of my head
any that looked at sleep quality i think
a lot of them looked at
uh
looking at substrate metabolism
especially the morning after um you know
looked at all sorts of stuff but i i
can't recall any of that looked at
it's very possible that they did and at
the time i read it i just simply didn't
care
yeah that's that's how i feel i've
this only recently has kind of popped
onto my my radar yeah like i said i've
seen like four or five of those studies
at this point i've read two of them and
i definitely wasn't reading for for
sleep related yeah
yeah we should revisit those and report
back if we find something interesting
all right so uh greg to play us out uh i
see that we've got uh do you not want to
take any of these other questions uh
we're pushing the time a little bit here
oh all right so i've got to get to them
but i am going to save them okay that
works
i'm interested to see if you think this
recipe here to play us out can compete
with the classic fig newton because
that's the first thing that came to mind
when i saw this
dude we've got a bunch in the fridge
downstairs you should you should grab
one on the way out well let's uh let's
tell the good people what we're talking
about here yeah so i um
this is this is food content as the to
play us out segment uh has largely
turned into
uh and a couple times in the last few
months i've made some
some uh
little streusel fruit bars that uh are
absolutely delicious and i'm going to
strongly recommend you make them
uh especially if you have a lot of uh
room for carbohydrate in your diet so um
recipe very straightforward uh there's
really only two things you need and that
is
streusel and fruit jam
so
you know i assume you're gonna make your
own streusel very easy to do um i i used
a uh a recipe or like a set of ratios
from sola l whaley uh who
puts out great food content i i think
i've i've shield her blondie recipe
before on the podcast you should check
out sola stuff uh she is excellent
what is streusel because i i know
obviously i know but some people might
some people might not know what streusel
is it is um
it's it's a wonderful thing that's large
okay that that clears it up
no it's so it's um
it's basically just like
dry ingredients
that you add enough butter to that it
could either be a crumble or a solid so
it's the type of thing where if you pack
it together it'll kind of hold together
as if it's a little snowball but if you
squeeze it it'll completely crumble back
to individual granules okay yeah yeah um
and so uh
the
so
the streusel itself for the amount of
bars that i made
four and a half cups of all-purpose
flour
two cups of some sort of granulated
sweetener plain sugar works fine
i made my own caramel sugar which that's
another thing double to play us out
let's take a quick little caramel sugar
detour
so um
i i don't know
why it occurred to me to try this but i
i did this for the first time maybe like
six months ago it's excellent now i keep
it on hands at all time um
so you you make caramel
you uh cool it you don't mix
any sort of fat or cream in as if you're
making like a caramel sauce you just
make caramel like you
cook the sugar till it starts
caramelizing you pour it into a pan you
let it completely solidify and then you
throw it into a food processor and just
let it go until it's completely
granulated and then it behaves
just like sugar except it tastes like
caramel so it's excellent um so anyway i
did 50 50 brown sugar and caramel sugar
but any sort of granulated sweetener
works fine so two cups of that
two cups of some type of textural mixin
so it could be nuts could be dried fruit
uh i just went with oatmeal
because i personally
like oatmeal for for fruit bars i think
it goes well
and then 30 tablespoons of butter which
is uh
almost four sticks so you melt that you
pour it over you just oh and just a
pinch of salt so that's your streusel
you mix it all together
check the texture just by seeing if it
will hold together if you squeeze it but
still crumble uh if it doesn't still
crumble if it still holds together a
little bit too much butter just add some
more flour and if it won't quite hold
together yet add a little bit more
butter it's very easy to tweak a
streusel
um so that's your streusel and then uh
the only other thing you need is some
form of fruit jam you can either make it
yourself or you could buy it
and that's it that's all there is to it
so you take two thirds of the streusel
you put it down in a parchment lined
baking sheet
for this amount of streusel it could
either be two smaller baking sheets or
one very large baking sheet uh mine's
like
19 and a half by 11 and a half inches so
it's it's a pretty big baking sheet and
this was the correct amount for a sheet
that large
uh you push you uh take about two thirds
of the streusel place it down in the pan
press it flat uh make sure there's no
little holes where the jam could flow
through to the bottom of the pan
um
you know you're lining a pan with
some sort of of doughy component pretty
straightforward uh then you take the jam
and you put it down on your streusel
layer
and
uh i i think i don't know the exact
amount of jam you should use
i weighed mine it was it was like uh
2100 grams give or take
um so i don't know is that like two
liters of jam that seems like a lot i
don't know whatever just get a bunch of
jam and just kind of play it play it by
ear play it by eye
you want there to be about the same
thickness of jam as there is your bottom
streusel layer so
uh maybe a maybe about a quarter of an
inch possibly a little bit uh thinner
than that
uh so you put the layer of jam down then
you take the other third of your
streusel and you you just crumble it
over the top
pop it in the oven at 350 and uh
again i didn't i didn't time it i don't
know how long i baked it for maybe like
40 minutes it's hard to say uh but it
was 350 fahrenheit and i just went until
the uh the top streusel layer is
starting to toast a little bit you can
smell those nice toasty flavors and the
jam is bubbling around the edges of the
pan
once you get there it's done you let it
cool
ideally cool in the fridge so it'll
solidify a little bit more
cut it into bars and
eat them they're so good
um
i
it is
other than ice cream because ice cream
is my favorite kind of desserty type
thing but outside of ice cream i think
it might be
my favorite uh
sweet confection that i've made
maybe not ever but but certainly in a
long long time what is the texture like
on a spectrum from like you know fig
newton is very soft and moist and then
on the other end of the spectrum i would
anchor it with the
nature valley granola bar that if you
break it it creates like 700 crumbs
where does it fall on that it's
somewhere between the two um it's
certainly not as
it's not as crunchy or crumbly as a
granola bar um
[Music]
but there is certainly more of a
textural contrast than a fig newton like
you
you have to use your teeth a little bit
to to get through it um but obviously
the jam is very very soft yeah
yeah as soon as we get done recording
you can have one cool that sounds great
yes sir
all right good stuff uh well thanks to
everybody for joining us in the totally
immersive stronger by science uh
multimedia
event here
uh formerly known as the podcast uh
let us know what you think about the the
new format if you're watching on youtube
with video uh you know let us know if
you like it we we certainly are open to
continuing it into the future but the
big news like i said is um
uh what's the date september 16th right
uh i think it's september
16th it'll be a week from when this
drops correct yeah a week from when this
episode goes live september 16th 8 p.m
eastern time we're going to have the
stronger by science
live stream on youtube uh to celebrate
the release of macro factor our diet app
we're also going to talk all about what
the app does probably answer some
listener questions should be a good time
and we'd love for you to join us live
and we will see you there